thank you for joining us i'm john
langler the counting of ballots here in
clark county is officially over
even with mounting lawsuits filed by the
trump campaign officials say everything
is finished on schedule but
we're still waiting to learn those
actual new vote totals
hector mejia is live at the clark county
election headquarters in north las vegas
with the latest
hector although there's nothing left to
count the final batch of unofficial
voting results will not get released
until sometime this afternoon
the county here says that they re they
received information they needed from
the state
just this morning so let's go over the
latest we've learned
that 1500 ballots are no longer eligible
because voters did not verify their
signature
before the deadline yesterday clark
county said it was sorting through
60 000 provisional ballots election
officials hoped
everything would be in the system by
midnight but there was a bit of a hang
up according to registrar
voters joe gloria in a press release
issued late last night
the secretary of state reported that not
all counties
had finished counting in-person
provisional ballots
cast by same-day registration voters and
here's why that led to a delay for us
here in clark county
according to gloria they weren't ready
to report and so did not submit their
provisional accounts
and individuals so there was we couldn't
complete our
confirmation that there were no double
votes in other counties so we couldn't
we couldn't move forward
we had to make sure we were able to
report against all 16 counties
is there a reason why i can't tell you i
don't i can tell you the clark county
was ready
the secretary of state did not specify
which counties were still counting
yesterday
we sent an email to find out and at the
time of this report we are still waiting
to hear
back and staff here will work through
the weekend to make sure
everything is ready to go for monday
monday at 1 pm
is when the votes will get certified at
the clark county government center
that's the latest from north las vegas
hector mejia 8 news now